[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois christine orban
pour son nouveau roman est ce que tu
danses la nuit ludivine benard pour son
livre sur la philosophe simone weil la
vérité pour vocation l'artiste
plasticienne carmen mariscal qui
exposent chez nous sa maison sa maison
cadenas place du palais royal du 12 mars
au 28 avril et la pièce i et de la
pianiste susan barr talent qui sort un
triple cd consacré aux années de
pèlerinage de franz liszt et elle les
interpréteront concert le 26 mars salle
cortot à paris mais comment sont comme
d'habitude par notre époque qu'est ce
qui la caractérise
voici votre réponse christine orban en
images tu ne lui veux c'est une liseuse
est en fait j'ai choisi cette image mais
je n'aime pas du tout lire sur le t2
c'est pour protester pour des revivre
les livres et
les crayons pour souligner et pour
écrire dans la marge
ça vous dérange pas qu'on écrive sur
voulez vous livre annonce ça me flatte
parce que quand j'écris sur un livre
c'est que je veux le prendre je me
gardais quand le réouvrir je prenne
jamais mes livres joffo des livres mais
je ne les prennent pas et je vais tout
de suite revoir les passages qui m'ont
éblouir souligné donc oui corner tout ça
c'est que c'est bon signe
c'est très bon signe même parfois je
trouve ça effrayant et je déchire un peu
j'ai une bibliothèque des livres et mais
c'est une bibliothèque qui est plein de
bonnes secondes et vous rentrez dans mon
bureau vous sentez que des bons et les
liseuses je crois pas que les livres
numériques aujourd'hui porte ombrage aux
livres en papier s'est pas véritablement
un succès alors qu'est-ce qui leur
portent ombrage parce que quand même
bien une sacrée ombre en ce moment c'est
possible au mieux votre votre image a
voulu divine bénard oui de cartes de la
chine oui voilà deux cartes de la chine
avant et après le coronavirus après non
mais pendant et surtout avant et après
la mise en stand by de la production
économique les gens qui restent chez eux
et ben voilà on a la réponse à la crise
écologique
oui à gauche donc la tache jaune sale
état jaune
oui ce sont des images de la nasa et
apparemment ce sont les émissions de
dioxyde d'azoté
donc ils sont émises par la combustion
fossile et c est donc lors du coroner
virus avec la mise en quarantaine des
personnes on se rend compte qu'il ya
plus de taches jaunes
voilà c'est merveilleux tout simplement
parce que les gens circulent mois
produisent moins exacts les usines sont
fermées et cetera et cetera donc moins
de pollution comme moi donc voilà il n'y
a pas besoin de multiplier les comme 21
il écope 22 et je souhaite pas de virus
mais on a quand même une idée de la
solution finalement c'est la
décroissance carmen mariscal votre image
à vous alors là sont pas des cada comme
on le fera c'est quoi ce sont des
menottes
oui oui ce sont de petites menottes
c'est une robe de mariée que j'ai fait
est que j'exposais à la maison de
l'amérique latine et un an un an et demi
sont c'est une robe de fée avec 1500
petites menottes et ça s'appelle l'
espace expo ça va parce qu'un espagnol
exposé à épouser épousé menottes
c'est le même nom et pour ce projet
j'avais invité plusieurs femmes des
différentes origines à participer à
rentrer dans la robe et dire ce que
c'était le mariage pour elle et j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses ça s'il y
avait des femmes dont il y avait des
femmes migrantes de réfugié politique
des femmes françaises aussi mexicaine
mais aussi des femmes
qui était dans une maison pour les
femmes issues de violence domestique et
après j'ai fait plein de visite avec
toutes les femmes et pour moi cette
photo avec les femmes à côté de la robe
qui dise stop cette violence ce top 7
elle dit stop parce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'elle car ici et
maintenant elle elle aussi mais elles
sont d or elles sont pas dedans d'accord
et pour moi cette image ça représente
aussi toutes les femmes qui sont dans
partout dans le monde maintenant dire
stop aux violences et les mains on dit
menottes et femmes mariées ça se dit la
même chose épouse et maintenant elle
même nom un espagnol c'était pas ça
expose à s'écroule
oui et votre image avoue susanna bartal
c'est celle ci mais c'est un airbus a380
alors je les choisis pour l'idée du
voyage le fait que aujourd'hui on peut
voyager partout et en très grande
vitesse aussi est justement les airbus
a380 à destination lointaine et en fait
ce qui engendrait que la vie s'est
accélérée la vie de tout le monde et moi
en tant qu'artiste par exemple je
ressens cela dans le fait que on peut
être n'importe où le lendemain d'un
concert donc en fait quand on nous
programmons on ya c'est assez un rythme
effréné qui n'existait pas avant et je
pense que c'est un peu dans la vie de
tout le monde
aujourd'hui on peut être à peu près dans
n'importe quel point du globe en 30
heures exactement donc c'est à dire que
ça c'est génial mais à la fois ça
fonctionne aussi à l'inversé qu'on nous
demande d'y être ce qui n'est pas
toujours aussi facile c'est à dire quand
il faut travailler entre guillemets
c'est pas un travail mais mais mais de
s'assurer la concert
j'ai juste c'est un métier et donc c'est
vrai que ça a beaucoup changé même si
bon
à être dans un avion comme ça c'est
agréable aussi oui enfin battant avec
l'empreinte carbone chez voilà voilà
donc il ya ça aussi ça soulève plein de
plein de sujets et bien commençons
[Musique]
commençons par voulu divine bénard et
votre essai sur la philosophe simone
weil intitulé la vérité pour vocation
qui vient de paraître aux éditions de
l'escargot alors pourquoi simone veil
qui est morte à 34 ans est elle si
importante
on ne cesse de la cité on la connaît mal
d'ailleurs on la confond avec la femme
politique
là c'est simone veil avait 40 w 34 ans
tu me dis très très courte
qu'est ce qu'elle a de particulier oui
j'ai passé les deux dernières années à
écrire un livre sur simone veil les à
devoir préciser systématiquement que
c'était simone veil -le avec un w parce
que les gens sont tout de suite très
enthousiaste oui simone veil
j'adore cette ministre non pas du tout
c'est simone veil une obscure philosophe
entre l'anarchisme et le socialisme du
début du xxème siècles obscurs passieu
pas sûr que ça ait la mémoire est quand
même vive
j'ai la mémoire est quand même vive
parmi les personnes qui ont eu accès aux
connaissances accès à la philosophie
moi qui viens d'un milieu populaire
simone veil il est inconnu et rapport à
simone de beauvoir qui elles sont
contemporaines elles se sont croisées
d'ailleurs à l'école normale supérieure
et et c'est vrai que tout le monde sait
qui et simone de beauvoir on c'est moi
qui ai simone veil
oui tout à fait donc c'était l'ambition
de l' ouvrage c'est est de la rendre
accessible et pourquoi simone veil dette
importante en 34 ans participer être à
la fois professeur de philosophie donner
des cours à des mineurs à des cheminots
s'engager sur le front de la guerre
d'espagne en 1936 aller à l'usiné en
1935 être aux côtés du général de gaulle
pendant la france avec la france libre à
londres pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
seulement 34 années d'existence déjà ça
vous pose ça vous pose en exemple et que
c'était vraiment une phase d'action
alors à la différence de 6 modes de
voir par exemple on peut dire que s'ils
me simone veil qui vial aussi d'une
famille bourgeoise qui est agrégé de
philosophie à 22 ans qui aurait pu avoir
une existence aussi confortable que
celle de simone de beauvoir que
l'existence confortable à part quelques
manifs dans les années 70 on peut pas
dire que véritablement des foyers autour
d'elle mais elle simone veil s'était il
elle fait des choix desquelles l
agrégation de philosophie elle est
nommée professeur de philo dans un lycée
de jeunes filles au puy en velay moyens
immédiatement elle s'engage auprès des
chômeurs elle vit comme eux c'est à dire
qu'elle est avec 5 francs par jour c'est
ça le reste de son de ses émoluments de
profs les donne aux caisses de pour
aider les chômeurs elle manifeste avec
une fait scandale tout de suite vous
avez vous avez tous lu c'est formidable
oui non et elle fait vraiment scandale
et au sens propre du terme parce que
elle va s'engager avec les chômeurs donc
elle va vouloir porter leurs
revendications à la mairie mais elle est
dans une position d'humilité c'est à
dire que simone veil le sait d'où elle
vient
elle sait qu'elle vient de la
bourgeoisie mais elle ne veut absolument
pas prendre la tête elle ne veut pas
être la tête pensante
elle ne veut pas que les intellectuels
prennent le pas sur le mouvement ouvrier
donc quand elle accompagne les
chauffeurs les chômeurs pardon à la
mairie elle est en retrait et à l'écouté
elle va peut-être les aider à expliciter
leur pensée à expliciter leur
revendication mais pas plus que ça mais
il en fallait pas plus pour que ce soit
le vrai scandale et qu'elle défraie la
chronique
on va on veut la révoquer et elle dit
elle cette phrase sur vidal que vous
citez me dit j'ai toujours considéré la
révocation comme le couronnement normal
d'une carrière oui oui parce que on
s'offusque on se dit mais quelle est
cette professeur de philosophie qui
déambulent avec les chômeurs à la sortie
du lycée qui leur sert la main les
chômeurs
du puy-en-velay sont payés par la mairie
fera sans payer sont occupés par la
mairie contre une maigre récompense à
casser des cailloux et elle va leur
serrer la main l île internationale avec
eux elle leur paye des coûts au bistrot
et sa défraie la chronique et oui elle
sera convoquée et ça va être une
pétition des parents d'élèves qui va la
sauver de parce qu'en plus les bottes
prof
puis elle est bonne prof et ses élèves
l'adorent et alors auprès s'attendre à
ce qu'elle devienne communiste
d'ailleurs lille humanité et pas du tout
elle est très anti communiste en fait
ben elle dessine même des marteaux
défaut si sur les copies des élèves mais
elle a été elle est un vrai penchant
pour les pour le communisme pour les
communistes pour ses camarades parce que
simone veil les quelques uns qui place
quand même l'humain avant tout mais elle
le dira je n'ai jamais envisagé de
prendre ma carte au parti et bien des
gens autour d'elle penser qu'elle
qu'elle apprendrait etc mais pas du tout
parce que très tôt à l'été 1932 elle
fait un voyage en allemagne et elle se
rend compte du mensonge aux soviétiques
elle trouve que le kpd le parti
communiste allemand ne fait rien pour
lutter contre hitler bien au contraire
il parle des paris qui veut y parvenir
oui oui voilà oui et elle trouve que
on n'entend pas du tout parlé de l'urss
en allemagne et que bien au contraire
l'urss n'a aucun intérêt à un mouvement
révolutionnaire sérieux en allemagne
parce que ça ne ferait que donner du
crédit à tous les opposants mais on voit
bien ce qui va permettre à simone veil
d'être somme toute
presque toujours du bon côté peut-être
toujours du bon côté c'est qu'elle se
méfie terriblement de l'état est ce une
individualiste au fond et elle est
contre l'état naturellement et les états
totalitaires ou les tailles terriblement
omniprésent ne peut
ne peuvent que lui déplaire ou la
dégoûter à mais tout à fait oui mais
l'état ou la collectivité au sens large
si ma nouvelle est une profonde
individualiste et sans tout ce que ça
peut avoir de négatif
sans tout ce que le terme peut avoir de
négatif aujourd'hui c'est pas quelle
place le jeu au dessus tout bien au
contraire elle dira plus tard qu'il faut
détruire le jeu mais le nous est encore
plus dangereux et elle le dira dans dans
sa célèbre note en 1940 contre les
partis politiques
il ne faut absolument pas que la pensée
soit empêchée ne faut pas
d'embrigadement de la pensée faut que la
pensée demeure rennes et la pensée n'est
pas rennes dans un état qui serait
presque totalitaire en germe en fait et
il n'est pas libre non plus dans un
parti politique ni dans une autre
doctrine
elle a fréquenté divers milieux au cours
de sa vie et à chaque fois elle a fini
par déplaire elle a fini par être seul
parce qu'elle critique elle ne pouvait
pas s'empêcher de critiquer ne pouvait
pas s'empêcher de dire ce qu'elle pense
et est donc finalement il ne pouvait pas
faire groupe avec les autres à 25 ans
elle cesse d'être professeur et elle
entre l usine
alors et alors attention pas du tout
comme les jeunes de mai 68 sont allé
s'établir en usine pour prêcher la bonne
parole aux ouvriers elle elle le fait
comme une expérience
c'est même plus que de l'expérience
finalement parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
n'y va pas comme les établis pour aller
prêcher la bonne parole pour dire il
faut se syndicaliser camarades
écoutez moi encore une fois elle est
tout à fait loin de ça elle veut sentir
dans sa chair elle déplore que les
grands chefs bolchevique comme elle dit
n'ai aucune idée de ce qui se passe à l'
usine et elle elle veut sentir ça dans
son coeur et dans sa chair et c'est
vraiment c'est plus que l'expérience
c'est vouloir toucher du doigt la vérité
oui la vérité son obsession de la vérité
qui aura toute sa vie en même temps elle
elle en conclut que jamais la révolution
viendra des ouvriers oui ce qu elle les
voit beaucoup trop soumis à des
conditions de travail tellement infernal
que elle peut pas imaginer une seconde
qui lui parviennent à maman de de briser
le joug mieux oui tout à fait mais parce
que ce qu'elle voit à l' usine c'est le
malheur que produit que produisent les
conditions de travail et ses conditions
de travail
elles vont détruire l'âme du travailleur
elles vont l'empêcher d'avoir un recul
sur lui d'avoir un retour
et finalement elle va et vient d'arriver
à la conclusion qu'il est impossible de
penser quand on travaille à l'usiné et
ça fait écho avec un livre que je lis en
ce moment qui est dans la dèche à paris
et à londres de george orwell et qui dit
il le dit beaucoup plus rapidement lui
le dit en quelques pages mais dit il la
travaille en tant que plongeur et il
fait des journées de 7h30 du matin
jusqu'à minuit ça n'en finit pas entre
les coups de feu et où il n'y a pas d'
espace tout le monde se bouscule c'est
atroce
il y en a pas le temps pensé on peut pas
penser et on peut juste quand le
week-end arrive se saouler et bien
simone veil -le va aller beaucoup plus
loin que ce que giorgio wyplay on dirait
vraiment elle va elle va elle va dresser
tout ce qui peut empêcher l'ouvrier de
penser la cadence des machines les
rythmes qui sont toujours divers variés
qui se contredisent
pourquoi la machine elle fonctionne pas
la non connaissance des machines et elle
va juste pouvoir constater qu' il ya un
renversement qui s'opère entre la
machine et l'ouvrier et l'ouvrier est
devenu une chose il est devenu de la
matière humaine et du coup ne plus
penser n'est plus humain et donc quelle
pourrait être la solution doit venir des
patrons c'est là où elle est l ai jamais
madické and see
yacé jamais les bons souffriez les
méchants patrons la solution doit venir
des patrons et le dialogue nécessaire
est entre les ouvriers et les patrons
oui tout à fait mais elle va envisager
enfin même pas même pas envisagées elle
va avoir une correspondance avec deux
patrons à sa sortie de l' usine pour
déterminer ce qui pourrait faire que ici
et maintenant les conditions dans
l'usiné s'améliore parce que la
révolution elle n'y croit pas il n'y a
pas de solidarité l usine l'ouvrier ne
pense pas et l'ouvrier ne fait pas
cohésion avec les autres ouvriers ne
fait pas bloc
il n'y aura pas de révolution donc elle
se dit qu'est ce qu'on est né en 1930
début des années 30 dont 36
on est juste un peu évolué aux
journalistes oui tout à fait bien
heureusement et donc elle va parler avec
ses dirigeants
et elle va quand même garder à l'esprit
que ce sont des dirigeants d'entreprise
et elle dira de l'un d'eux elle aura
travaillé dans une de ses usines et elle
dira c'est un homme admirable mais je
n'oublie pas le malheur qu'il y a dans
son usine et donc elle va essayer avec
eux de voir in concreto ce qui est ce
qui peut être fait pour qu'on puisse
passer d'une collaboration lé palais
jamai dans le les patrons sont tous
méchants il ne faut pas leur parler elle
n'est pas du tout comme ça elle se
convertit au catholicisme
alors qu'elle vient d'une famille
d'origine juive mais totalement athée et
elle même est agnostique et elle se
convertit au catholicisme
qu'est ce qu'elle va trouver dans lequel
tony 6 ou l'amour des pauvres alors elle
se convertit pas au catholicisme
elle va se rapprocher du christianisme
le catholicisme a l'impression de sentir
très proches mais elle ira pas vraiment
jusqu'à la conversion parce qu'elle va
se refuser aux baptêmes
elle dira je ne peux pas recevoir le
baptême parce que l'église ne voudrais
pas me donner le baptême dans les
conditions dans lesquelles je pense
parce que je ne veux pas penser dans les
clous je ne veux pas penser je ne veux
pas croire comme l'église voudrait que
je crois et les com'zones tout le temps
en fait oui oui oui non vraiment elle
n'arrive à être
jamais confort finalement et là encore
elle dit elle préfère dialoguer
directement que le patron le christ donc
et ya la guerre d'espagne
elle va se battre avec les avec les
anarchistes là encore il faut voir c'est
la koala 26 ans si la télé il sort de
lusine quand même hélas elle part sur le
front comme journaliste enfin elle fait
le coup de fusil assez vite et surtout
elle voit lorsqu'elles appellent le
règne de la force
et là encore pas de manichéisme elle
voit son camp aussi noir que le camp
d'en face
oui c'est ça la chagrinera certainement
oui parce que au début elle par la
guerre d'espagne en se disant je ne
supporte pas la position de l'ariège je
ne supporte pas de vivre ma vie
aujourd'hui dans le confort parisien
tout en sachant que tout les joue tous
les jours toutes les heures je pense à
la victoire des uns en espagne et à la
défaite des autres
donc elle va vouloir y aller et tout le
monde la panse folle d'ailleurs il ya
juste à avoir les échos de certains de
ses camarades sur place elle ne savait
pas manier les armes elle faisait peur à
tout le monde
elle n'a jamais eu un sens servir elle
n'a jamais tué personne sur place mais
dieu soit loué et elle s'en serait
peut-être pas remise
et donc oui sur place elle va être avec
ses camarades anarchistes de la colonne
international durruty est ce qu'elle va
voir finalement c'est que tous ces
militants anarchistes qui militait pour
les plus grande valeur pour les plus
justes causes et bien finalement ils
sont prêts à les paupières atrocités ils
sont prêts à la torture ils sont prêts
au crime pour que triomphent leur vérité
à eux qui seraient supérieurs et donc
ils sont prêts à assassiner des
franquistes et ça il ne peut pas le
supporter là aussi elles dénoncent
l'emprise du collectif c'est toujours ça
c'est le collectif pour éduquer qui est
catastrophique
oui tous mais hélas en plus du collectif
c'est qu'elle va sentir une vraie une
vraie haine du camp d'en face est une
vraie soif de vaincre et elle va la
sentir en elle même ce désir de tuer
elle va le sentir en elle-même et elle
va se dire c'est ça qui est encore plus
effrayant mais c'est certainement ce qui
la rendent particulièrement intéressante
aujourd'hui simone veil
c'est justement qu'aujourd'hui on a
tendance à a dénoncé à tire larigot
l'individualisme et dira le collectif
c'était quand même mieux
remettons du collectif etc etc et l ai
dit non
oui tout à fait mais après c'est pas
pour un individualisme je serai là
darcis 6 non narcissisme non mais oui
effectivement elle elle met en garde
contre les collectifs parce que je mets
en garde l'individu contre le collectif
ce que le collectif peut le faire
devenir tout à fait et après il faut
souvent quand même se souvenir qu'on a à
l'époque des grandes masses et c'est
vrai que tout ce qu'elle a pu voir dans
chacune de ces masques on parle des
communistes qu'on parle des anarchistes
qu'elle a vu en espagne
à chaque fois elle ya trouvé à critiquer
oui mais il ya aussi la guerre qui a
servi elle peut pour elle ça la guerre
nous a servi encore plus que le
capitalisme donc oui c'est tout à fait
parce que pendant la période de guerre
l'état le pouvoir de d'envoyer à la mort
et ça c'est encore plus terrible que
l'oppression qu'on peut vivre en usine
ou quoi que ce soit c'est que la l'état
décide de la vie ou de la mort des gens
elle est pacifiste elle est très
longtemps pacifiste c'est une conviction
qu'elle tient de son professeur de
philosophie alain qui a été traumatisée
ans par les massacres de la grande
guerre et elle va tenir son pacifisme
très longtemps elle va le tenir
jusqu'aux accords de munich
elle sera pour aller me because he les
munichois est tout à fait et quand
hitler va trahir ces accords elle en
viendra enfin à la conclusion qu'aucun
accord n'est possible avec claire et que
la guerre va se profile donc en fait
elle est bénie coise mais quand quelques
mois plus tard ils marchent sur prague
là il dit là il faut faire la guerre oui
la nature après elle s'en voudra plus
tard elle
elle se repentira de cette terrible
erreur criminelle et elle mettra ça
aussi sur le content d'avoir été
pacifiste oui d'avoir été passif
eastwood elle seule elle s'en repentira
elle dira je souffrais d'atroces
migraines et je n'ai pas je n'ai pas eu
les idées claires à ce moment là pour
elle la lutte des classes ne doit pas
passer par la guerre puisque la guerre
nous a servi mais est-ce que ça passe
par la révolution
j'ai l'impression qu'elle voit la
révolution font comme la guerre elle
reste aux révolutionnaires mais avec
tout ce que la révolution apportée en
urss avec tout ce qu'elle peut critiquer
l2 sur la révolution soviétique telle
qu'elle l'a vu elle reste frileuse quand
même elle elle ne nourrit guère
d'illusions sur les démocraties aussi on
voit bien pour elle une démocratie au
fond les démocraties de l'époque la
france angleterre ce sont des empires
coloniaux et elle va voir dans les
systèmes totalitaires et dans le nazisme
en particulier un colonialisme du même
type que celui qu'on exerce dans en
afrique ou en asie
oui tout à fait jamais pour elle la
france n'était exemplaire parce que
justement la france a les mains salies
de ce qu'elle fait aux colonies et s'est
elle dit tout ça dans les années 30 il
faut bien se souvenir oui oui c'est fait
elle n'attend pas les années 50 60
c'est dans les années 30 elle a beaucoup
d' avance sur son époque de ce point de
vue là après elles gardent une vision
qui reste paternaliste elle pensera
n'ont pas tout de suite à l'indépendance
des colonies mais à comment on peut
cohabiter comment on peut il peut y
avoir des échanges mais elle continue de
penser le rapport de la france à ses
colonies dans une sorte de protection
mais effectivement le ce qui va la
pousser aussi à vouloir à vouloir la
guerre contre hitler a finalement s'y
résoudre
c'est qu'elle conçoit que la menace d'
hitler c'est celle d'une colonisation
c'est-à-dire celle de la fin de notre
civilisation
elles s'appuient souvent sur l'exemple
de la domination romaine la domination
antique romaine et
si les romains ont détruit des
civilisations dont aujourd'hui on entend
on n'entend plus parler on ne les
connaît pas elles ont été complètement
annihilés et bien elle a peur que ce
qu'hitler face à la france c'est ça et
que notre civilisation disparaissent
elle va entrer dans la résistance
mais ce qu'elle veut c'est aller à
londres elle va aller à londres et c'est
là qu'elle va mourir elle est morte de
quoi elle est morte de quoi baisse à 10
déplacements
oui on dit des musiques d'épuisement oui
est vraisemblable mais c'est assez
vraisemblable parce que elle a contracté
la tuberculose
elle refuse de se nourrir et quand il
faudra vraiment se nourrir elle ne le
pourra plus physiquement l oiseau 43 oui
c'est ça on est en 43 est mais elle
aussi morte de désespoir c'est ce que je
précise à la fin de mon livre c'est que
je remets en cause le fait qu'elle se
serait suicidé parce qu'il ya une espèce
d'idée romantique ou simone veil
distribuer ces tickets de rationnement
au camp des réfugiés voisin
ce qu'elle faisait 1 il ne supportait
pas d'avoir plus que ce que les petits
français ne pouvait avoir
mais à côté de ça elle est surtout morte
de désespoir parce que elle ce qu'elle
voulait c'était revenir en france elle
et quand elle était en france en 1940
elle était encore avec ses parents ils
étaient tous là on l'a dit ils étaient
tous juifs donc ils étaient tous en
danger et elle ne pouvait pas prendre le
risque de mettre ses parents en danger
donc elle les emmènera aux états unis et
à partir de là il s'en voudra atrocement
et d'être partis de france est donc ce
qu'elle voudra rejoindre londres pour
participer aux combats
elle arrive à rejoindre londres et quand
elle rejoint londres et dit je veux être
parachuté je veux être parachuté les
armes à la main je veux me battre contre
les nazis
tout le monde la trouve paul dhaeyer
général de gaulle gars mais cette femme
est folle et personne ne voudra voudra
accédé à ces demandes
et finalement il restera à londres
tuberculeuse avec des migraines de plus
en plus terrible elle écrira nuitées
jour elle se nourrira à peine est elle
restera avec cette idée qu'elle manque
sa vocation et qu'elle est à l'ombre en
sécurité pendant que pendant que se joue
la vraie scène où elle devrait être
et elle n'y est pas et ça c'est terrible
au poil vous connaissiez simone veil
avait lu le racisme en l'enracinant
qu'elle son dernier livre il paraîtra
après après la guerre tout à fait qui
sera édité par cas mais oui avec un
chapitre enfin nouvelles ou quelques
pages formidable sur l'âme
kim avait ébloui à l'époque longtemps
beau sujet je me devais y
oui en fait je connaissais pas ce que
j'ai à la compositrice sa grande
compositrice finlandaise qui a fait une
pièce qui s'appelle passion la passion
de simone est en fait justement c'était
un très beau spectacle aussi avec des
projections justement avec avec simon
nouvelle et je me suis dit maintien
c'est pas la ministre du coup cela m'a
poussé justement à a
à faire quelques recherches sur l est en
effet en fait ça m'a beaucoup marqué ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure parce que
moi je suis né en roumanie dans une
famille hongroise et j'ai une grande
tente qui est justement morte dans un
goulag
donc c'est vrai que l'idée du parti
communiste d'avoir sa carte dans le
parti ça résonne un peu bizarrement pour
moi surtout que par exemple ma grand
mère a été exclu du parti communiste
elle a perdu ça car c'est vraiment ravi
d'être vivante mais elle n'a jamais
retrouvé du travail dans son métier donc
donc disons que je la trouve visionnaire
c'est aussi simone à ce niveau là
d'avoir pu se dissocier justement
d'autres intellectuels qui normal c'est
humain de tomber un petit peu dans le
piège des idéaux du communiste qui en
soi sont très beaux mais dans leur
réalisation peut-être ont laissé ont
fait beaucoup de dégâts quand même et je
trouve que on parle beaucoup des nazis
ce que ce qui est ce qui est très bien
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier mais je
trouve que c'est bien que de plus en
plus on parle aussi des dégâts qu'on
cassait le communisme et tous ces
régimes qu'on imagine peut-être pas par
l'otan la vérité pour vocation simone
veil la vérité pour vocation c'est signé
ludivine bénard essai paru aux éditions
de l'escargot ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
des invités sont aujourd'hui ludivine
bénard l'auteur de simone veil la vérité
pour vocation l'artiste plasticienne
carmen mariscal qui exposent chez nous
sa maison que la cadna place du palais
royal du 12 mars au 28 avril la pianiste
susanna bartal qui sort un triple cd
consacré aux années de pèlerinage de
franz liszt et les interpréteront
concert le 26 mars à la salle cortot à
paris et christine orban pour son
nouveau roman est ce que tu danses la
nuit qui vient de paraître chez albin
michel
c'est un roman que vous avez dédié une
jeune femme inconnue qui sans le savoir
vous est donné l'idée de ce livre est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire dans quelles
circonstances qu est ce qu elle a dit
qu'ils vivent toutacoo allumez votre
colère je sais chez albin michel parce
que sinon oui oui nouveau livre sur
cfoot michel à tous mes livres censée
albin michel
c'était gt lors d'un dîner ou à la fin
du dîner le maître de maison propose de
poser chacun une question est tournée et
une jeune femme très jeune femme en face
de moi tire une question et elle blêmi
et on se demande quelle est cette
question et elle dit
avez vous un secret et alors on la
regarde tous els silence et puis tout
d'un coup elle dit j'ai aimé le père de
mon petit m
et je suis sorti de là et je lui ai dit
que ça l'a dit que ça et je me suis dit
je vais écrire cette histoire vous
n'avez pas interroger vous l'avais
imaginé cette histoire je les imaginais
et je les ai souvent observés je dirais
chez les jeunes femmes
alors pas forcément pour le père du
petit ami ce qui complique la situation
mais mais la fascination d'abord la
différence de maturité entre une fille
de 18 ans et un garçon de 18 ans je
n'aime pas du tout les de faire des
généralités mais souvent les les filles
sont les femmes sont plus matures les
jeunes femmes et parfois la fascination
qu'elles peuvent avoir pour un homme un
peu plus âgés ou pour vous plus âgés
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui a été
souvent traités on va dire et dans la
littérature dans le cinéma
l'idée de la jeune femme une très jeune
fille elle était adolescente et c'est la
première fois qu'elle fait l'amour avec
son petit ami que quasiment qu'elle
rencontre aussi le père du petit ami et
qui ne la laisse pas indifférente et lui
non plus n'est pas indifférent elle ça
en revanche ça a été quasiment jamais
traité je me suis demandée j'essayais de
me souvenir je n'ai rien vu je ne me
souviens de rien qui parle de cette
histoire là c'est un amour déplacés moi
non plus j'ai pas c'est pas en plus il
va y avoir beaucoup d'heureux
rebondissements donc l'histoire et est
aussi sûr il ya beaucoup de sujets dans
ce sujet là je alors ma souligné que
c'était une construction qui faisait
penser un peu aux alors ç'a l'air
prétentieux de dire ça mais au théâtre
grec mais en effet s'est pas fait mais
enfin c'est pas hippolyte c'est pas le
roi m'aider mais il ya il ya quelque
chose comme ça avec avec la destinée et
la transgression
même si c'est pas un amour interdit
je n'en ménage ou scandaleux c'est un
amour scandaleux et ça m'intéressait
beaucoup de d'abord de travailler sur le
secret et sur le lourd à porter tout de
même pour une jeune fille de cet âge est
sûr aussi le scandale si ça se sait donc
le secret est obligatoire quand elle
voit le père elle dit est dit que le
fils existe moins quand son père est là
en fait le père annuler le fils oui
c'est que j'écris parce que j'écris
d'être j'essaie d'être un troisième
personne puis temps en temps je peux pas
m'empêcher dans la dalle est dans la
tête de chacun pour pour mieux vivre et
est en effet narrateur narratrice nice a
surtout quand il arrive la première fois
chez le père que le fils est et est fier
de son père damman le père et 4
charismatique il est très beau les
cheveux gris il a réussi et le fils
aille mal à l'école et va demander de
l'argent de poche au père et elle se
sont humiliés parce que le fils dans la
main demande le père donne et elle se
dit je suis moi assimilé à ce jeune
homme elle se sent tout de suite elle
qui gagne son argent de poche toutes
seules qui travaillent dans les musées
et tout d'un coup et n'approuve pas ce
comportement alors cet impair assez
entreprenants ils sont en voiture est
alors que lui conduit l etat côté le
fils le petit ami est à l'arrière il
somnole et lui demande de poser sa tête
sur ses genoux pendant tout le conduit
et cette scène alors elle est très bonne
mais on se dit c'est invraisemblable et
en fait on comprendrait des rares un
vrai sens ils savaient pas
invraisemblable cela ne l'est pas
vraiment pas mais j'ai voulu faire des
personnages humains
j'ai essayé de construire chacun le
pavec une psychologie comme s'il pouvait
exister et après c'était c'est assez
extraordinaire mais je crois que les
romanciers ressenti ça après quelques
pages les personnages deviennent des
personnes et c'est eux qui vous
racontent l'histoire et je j'ai senti
l'humanité cet homme est un est un homme
bien on dit un gentleman dans les
affaires on lui connaît pas énormément
d' aventure c'est pas un coureur de
jupons comme on dit mais tout d'un coup
la nature revient et surtout j'ai
construit comme des excuses pour chacun
il est veuf il vient de enfin il a perdu
deux ans auparavant
sa compagne est il
il est obsédé par la mort et tout d'un
coup la vision de cette jeune fille va
aussi lui redonner vie politique il est
géant séducteur égoïste
oui c'est ce que la millions bisson fils
ils sont achetés ce que j'ai voulu dire
parce que c'est un livre aussi sur le
désir qui à un moment donné devient plus
plus fort que la morale chez des gens
bien il s'agit pas de criminels pas de
pédophile ce sont des gens j'allais dire
normaux à ce que la normalité exigences
et bien m'aimer
mais il n'y a pas de crime pas néanmoins
elle consent d'ailleurs elle et elle
consent à cette histoire d'amour mais en
même temps on ressent bien calé on
dirait aujourd'hui sous emprise
samedi soir elle la raconte 25 ans après
elle pourrait aussi la raconter en dix
ans et d'ailleurs il ya des mots elle a
cédé s'est abandonnée elle était
prisonnière elle dit à un moment qui lui
est impossible de rien refuser à cet
homme là on est déjà dans une
construction où ça pourrait être un acte
d'accusation
alors j'ai pensé évidemment à l'emprise
qu'il s'agit absolument pas d'emprise
il s'agit d'admiration et je trouve que
il faut pas confondre l'admiration
avec avec avec l'emprise elle avec la
domination c'est de l'admiration je
pense que si le père lui avait dit tu es
trop jeune tu as 18 ans elle est non
elle aurait eu un grand chagrin d'amour
et puis en même temps s'il vient après
pour la console et c'est que le fils l'a
laissé tomber pour une injustice parce
qu'il a les défauts de la jeunesse il
est impulsif lui est assez violent et il
voit une moto garée devant chez lui il
est sûr qu'elle le trompait il la met
quatre mois les preuves et revient la
consoler et ensuite le fils reviendra
etc etc va pas raconter tous les
rebondissements ce qui y est elle et
elle est assez mal à l'aise on est dans
l'immoralité tout le temps dans cette
histoire elle sort non seulement avec un
homme plus âgé mais c'est pas ton ça
c'est parce que c'est le père de son
petit de son petit ami oui même s'il
n'est plus son petit ami il cherche à le
redevenir il ne sait pas quelle était
également avec son père tout ça est
épouvantable à quoi est-ce qu on
reconnaît qu'on fait le mal dans une
histoire à bourges
aujourd'hui on aime pas mais qu'un
couteau elle elle va le reconnaître
quand le alors je veux pas raconter
toute l'histoire mais quand le père va
perdre la tête puis le fils est là et
elle sent que c'est trop je sais pas si
vous avez lu un amour de boutaty qui est
un livre que j'adore c'est l'histoire
d'un architecte qui est saint quentin
année qui est mené par le bout du nez
par une comédie une petite
milanaise et et il est totalement
conscient mais il peut pas résister il
est là il est là cet homme qui se
maîtrise qui
qui dirige une société qui tout d'un
coup va être pris par cette jeune fille
et vous parlez d'emprise c'est quand
même elle qui mène le jeu bien entendu
donc mais elle pourrait aussi 25 ans
après se dire après tout c'était
important qu'ils aient pas de regrets
non je sais pas une histoire où l'on
regrette ça fait partie il y a des
moments de vie qu'on doit vivre
est-ce que tu danses la nuit c'est le
titre du nouveau roman de christine
orban qui vient de paraître chez albin
michel
[Musique]
on continue dans l'amour avec karmann
mariscal vous êtes artiste plasticienne
vous êtes mexicaine mais vous vivez
entre londres et paris aujourd'hui et
vous travaillez depuis quelques temps
sur les cadavres que les les couples
d'amoureux accroche sur les ponts un peu
partout dans les grandes villes en
france c'est plutôt sur le pont des arts
le pont de l'archevêché la passerelle
léopold-sédar-senghor haut sur la place
du palais royal que l'on voit ici alors
la place du palais royal un pas le
jardin du palais royal la place du
palais royal qui est entre le louvre et
le conseil d'état à deux pas du jardin
du palais-royal du 12 mars au 28 avril
vous aller exposer cette cette oeuvre
qui s'intitule chez nous je vous propose
qu'on regarde une petite vidéo on va
mieux comprendre
[Musique]
m
pour
[Musique]
à
tous
l'oeuvre exposait fait à peu près 3 m 2
ou 3 mètres de long mais il y en
ad'autres fait à partir de cadenas y
compris d'autres maisons comme celle ci
alors pourquoi tout à coup ces cadenas
d'amour eux
on vit votre imagination la chose que
j'aime le plus de paris c'est traverser
les ponts et pendant que je traverse l
éponge je regardais à chaque fois les
ponts se remplir des quatre noms et je
me disais et je voyais le couple qui le
mettait le couple qui venait de partout
et paris c'était devenu la capitale
on s'est toujours la capitale de l'amour
mais la capitale de l'amour avec des cas
demain je me suis dit là quelle horreur
et après je me suis dit pourquoi est ce
que les gens choisissent un calvin pour
présenter l'amour si c'est exactement le
contraire
bon bien sûr le cadenas peut symboliser
la sécurité mais aussi c'est
l'appartenance si je me dis et après les
gens jettent la clé dans la seine alors
une autre heure je me suis dit 'pourquoi
or parce que je te la clé dans la seine
oui parce qu'il ferme
il ferme les cas demain si vous le ferez
pas ce soir oui mais gaffe à la clé et
la jette dans la seine
et puis la scène et tout pollué je me
suis dit bon qu'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire avec
avec ma ville d'adoption que j'aime
tellement lorsqu'elle dit c'est partout
vous savez qui a commencé deux ans et
que ces cadenas ça commençait aussi en
italie c'est les serbes allaient ferme
ça fait un siècle que les serbes mettent
des cadenas ce sera un pont et ensuite
ils belgrade et puis après ça c'est dit
c'est billy de toute l'europe
peut-être dans le monde et et puis aussi
au pays de galles ils ont des cuillères
qui représente l'amour qui ont des
cadenas aussi mais bon les cadenas ça
aussi dans l'époque au moyen âge les
maris mettait de canal aux femmes dos
quel genre d'exploration des choses
comme ça mais ma ceinture de chasteté
sud les gens bref de toute façon je
trouve que le symbole de l'amour que les
4,9 et pas tellement le symbole de
l'amour et c'est comme ça qu'on trouve
les quatre ans aujourd'hui et alors
cette maison je trie qu'on revienne à la
maison qu'on va qu'on va voir chez soi
c'est une maison
qui serait presque le nid idéal pour une
histoire d'amour sauf qu'à des cadenas
vous en ai mis vous avez des 4 da
partout là c'est pas exactement que j'ai
mis des cadenas c'est une maison qui a
ni portes ni fenêtres ni cheminée alors
c'est une forme de maison de prison qui
est fait tous les murs on fait avec les
grilles du pont de l'archevêché
alors il faut savoir que ces cadenas
seront enlevés régulièrement parce que
ça fait s'affaisser les ponts et vous
vous êtes allée les récupérer en fait
une fois qu'on les a enlevées je vois
qu'on voit il ya une très courte vidéo
que vous avez réalisé qui est qui et qui
dure dix sept secondes mais c'est pour
voir où est ce qu'ils étaient ces
cadenas trice que vous êtes allé les
ramasser et regarder
c'est quoi cette un cimetière de moi je
l'appelle le cimetière de l'amour parce
que c'est l'endroit où vont tous les cas
demain même les cannois qui sont dans la
maison tous appartient à la ville de
paris
c'est la ville de paris qui me les a
prêtés je dois les rendre ah oui oui à
l'objet c'est une sculpture qu'on ne
peut pas acheter cet effet mais renonce
appartient la ville de paris les cadenas
appartient alors je suis allé là pour
choisir les grilles qu'on allait m et
puis bon j'ai travaillé avec une équipe
extraordinaire parce qu'elles sont très
très très lourde
la maison va faire presque 5 tonnes est
ce que vous espérez sait que ça va être
dissuadés définitivement les gens
d'accrocher des cadenas sur les ponts
bon je pense que ça je pense que oui et
je pense que la mairie de paris aimerait
bien ça aussi mais surtout c'est de se
poser la question sur sur l'amour comme
possession que font les gens d'ailleurs
puisque vous en avez interrogé quand ils
se sont séparés
est ce qu'ils essayent de récupérer le
cadenas oui vous pourrez pas imaginer la
capacité des gens qui m'écrivent
maintenant est ce que si tu vois mon
petit canal j il ya des millions que moi
il y en a qui viennent et qui a essayé
d'enlever le cadenas qu'ils avaient
accroché 6 mois ou un an avant ça je ne
sais pas mais il me demande de chercher
les leurs gentil mais c'est impossible
mais bon chaque ce qui me touchait
beaucoup c'est que chaque cas mince et
c'est comme une espèce de les charger de
mémoire on voit les normes collectives
des deux petites histoires ensemble
ouais et est-ce que vous avez vu parfois
plusieurs cadenas la même personne qui
aurait mis plusieurs cadres avec des
personnes différentes je les ai pas
suivi mais il y en a tellement mais
parfois comme ça ils ont accroché les
uns avec les autres
vous avez déjà accroché un cadenas mais
si normand jamais non plus une arme vous
non plus n'ont personne ne vient que
personne ne se démonte jamais quand on
possède et bien donc l'exposition se
sera battu 12 mars donc lundi ça
commence à être montés
lundi ce sera monté sur la place du
palais royal juste devant la l'entrée
l'entrée du louvre et ça durera jusqu'au
28 avril
[Musique]
susanna bartal vous êtes pianiste et
vous venez d'enregistrer un triple cd
consacré aux années de pèlerinage de
franz liszt
alors c'est quoi les années de
pèlerinage ce qu'on pourrait croire
comme ça que ce sont des années pendant
lesquelles il était pèlerins mais non il
a fini à b tout aurait pu l pèlerins
mais oui j'ai exactement ça donc je
pense qu'il ya l'idée du voyage est
aussi du mysticisme
en fait je peux relies on parlait
d'amour scandaleux trailer bon c'était
un autre amour scandaleux qui était à
l'origine de ces années de pèlerinage
chez liszt donc lisible que deux amours
scandaleuses
oui enfin bon un de ses amours
scandaleuses était celui avec la
comtesse marie d'agoult donc qui était
marié et donc liste a fait scandale en
étant avec elle ils ont dû fuir la
france et s'installer à genève
c'était dans la première moitié du 19e
c'est l'exact la sécurité des années
1830 des années 1840 et donc ils ont ils
ont vécu d'abord en suisse d'où le
premier volume des années de pèlerinage
est intitulé suisse et donc ça décrit un
petit peu les voyages qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup de scènes bucoliques de mature
etc mais toujours avec la présence de
l'humain avec beaucoup de citations
littéraires aussi parce qu'ils composent
énormément il compose normalement et il
est dans une espèce d'effervescence
littéraire aussi donc hors ya même des
grandes citations de byron de schiller
de voir kantisme voilà exactement est en
plein dans le roman ensuite ils ont ils
ont beaucoup voyagé en italie donc le
deuxième volume dates à peu près la même
période
voilà où la ces michel-ange
voilà les
les sonnets de pétrarque dans l'enfer de
dante
voilà encore une fois cette
effervescence et puis attendez que je
vous arrête parce que c'est là qu'ils y
aillent se trouve que vous avez
enregistré un clip d'un de ses morceaux
de la deuxième année on sait ce qu une
tarentelle la tarentelle qui est donc
fait partie du supplément de la deuxième
année venaient dinapoli
voilà qu'il a rajouté à la fin des
années 1850 on vous écoute et on vous
regarde l'interpréter c'est assez
virtuose à jouer cette parenthèse très
difficile
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
e
m
[Musique]
susanna bartal quand je vous vois
l'interpréter comme ça je me dis mais on
a vu vous n'aviez pas de partition avec
quelle mémoire le jouet vous est ce que
c'est la mémoire visuelle vous souvenez
de la partition est ce que c'est la
mémoire tactiles sont vous dois qui
courent sur le piano qui savent
parfaitement où il faut il faut talent
et c'est une mémoire audio vous savez
qu'elle devient violent après
s'apprêtent elles notent quand ça se
passe alors pour ce cycle je pense que
c'était vraiment un défi parce que vous
parlez des trois disques en fait ça
représente trois heures de musique et en
fait je les ai donnés à chaque fois que
je les donne en concert en intégrale sur
une après midi ou une journée c'est par
coeur ce sera le seul à nous importons
le 26 mai au concert de suite d'une
heure chaque écran avec oz et donc
c'était un vrai défi c'est un ensemble
de tout ce que vous évoquez parce qu'en
fait bon moi je fonctionne beaucoup sur
la mémoire auditive je me souviens que
même des textes quand je dois les
apprendre je les apprends mieux quand je
les lis à voix haute
après c'est aussi une mémoire tactile
mais pour par exemple se souvenir
vraiment avec précision de ces trois
heures j'ai vraiment analyser dans ma
tête
exactement comment fonctionnait cette
musique c'est à dire que le propre de
ces génies compositeur c'est quand même
qu'il ya une logique
vraiment c'est ils ont pas qu'ils ont
pas mis ce à n'importe comment et donc
est donc une fois qu'on a analysé ça
permet quand même beaucoup mieux de s'en
souvenir
il faut il faut il faut l'assumer sur
scène quand même il faut dire à vous de
ce qu'on appelle la troisième année des
années de pèlerinage placé à la fin de
sa vie quand il est devenu abbé après
une rupture avec une autre histoire
d'amour très mal à l'aise avec la
princesse caroline sayn wittgenstein
avec qui il a vécu pendant 12 13 ans
sans être mariés qui n'ont plus et plus
personne ne la recevait lé cet ep oui
mais ils voulaient voler puis le pape
voulait pas dissoudre son mariage raté
jusque mardi soir atroce parce que
jusqu'au dernier moment ils croient
qu'ils vont enfin pouvoir se marier et
ils ont la veille du mariage on leur
apporte la réponse du pape on leur dit
non vous pouvez pas et ensuite le mari
de cette femme meurt mais c'est trop
tard il n'en avons pas oui je pense que
ça devient tellement terrible pour
police parce que quand même grand
catholique n'est ce pas bon après il est
devenu abbé mais même je pense le
mysticisme est présent tout au long de
sa vie même quand il vivait
scandaleusement je pense que c'était
très important pour lui est donc la
troisième année c'est plus épuré
s'éteint c'est un volume qui n'a
absolument rien à voir avec les deux
autres volumes
disons qu'il s'est écoulé aussi 40 à peu
près 40 ans 35 à 40 ans et donc cette
virtuosité que vous voyez par exemple
dans la tarentelle ou dans d'autres
pièces dans des deux premiers volumes
on le trouve un tout petit peu dans la
pièce qui est assez connu les jeux doit
à la villa d'este donc ça c'est assez
assez virtuose encore mais toutes les
six autres pièces sont vraiment vraiment
mystique jusqu'à par exemple à la
dernière pièce qui s'appelle source une
corde à élever vos coeurs donc c'est
vraiment le link est ce que c'est parce
que vous êtes d'origine hongroise ce que
vous avez eu envie de jouer du liste
parce que lui-même était en grand en
tout cas se vivait comme tel en partie
aussi parce que celle des plus grands
génies compositeur et pianiste mais
l'idée d'origine est venue d'un
organisateur qui me dit tiens tu es
hongroise était pianiste est ce que tu
voudrais faire l'intégrale des années de
pèlerinage qui réfléchissent à bombay
j'ai dit oui et dans les dix 10 minutes
qui ont suivi je suis assez quand même
200 et quelques pages je n'ai pas encore
joué aux crimes de ses pièces en concert
mais bon j'aime bien les défis alors il
faut il faut s'ouvrir quand même que
liste on croit toujours que la la
starisation cette date du 20e siècle de
la télévision dont liszt était une
immense star les mois c'est qu'il avait
s'arrête sur des mugs sondés sur des
vagues at il annoncé
scène il a connu savent bien avant les
beatles bien avant elvis presley
il n'était pas le seul le shop a vécu à
peu près la même chose et voltaire et
rousseau
voilà il y avait des stars avant et on a
même parlé de lisztomania absolument en
croûte a fait tout à fait puisque c'est
vraiment avec lui je pense liste et
paganini que vraiment le mythe du
virtuose interprète s'est installé à
partir du 19ème siècle
merci tout les 4 d'avoir participé à
cette émission années de pèlerinage de
france nice le triple cd sorti chez
naïve et vous serez en concert le 26
mars salle cortot vous les
interpréteront les trois années de suite
chez nous livre de carmen mariscal sera
visible au palais non place du palais
royal du 12 mars au 28 avril simone veil
la vérité pour vocation le livre de
ludivine bénard séparés aux éditions de
l'escargot est est ce que tu danses la
nuit le nouveau roman de christine orban
sécher allard b albin michel
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]